father is finding it difficult to
process who I am as a person I gotta say
I'm pretty excited it's time and I want
people to start talking about what our
characters get to do this season and
rather than it living in my head 2022
CSA best comedy series no big deal but a
huge deal congratulations on that
what is normal
yeah
easy
uncomplicated probably what Rachel
McAdams has season two I think is the
season of Love will we
in a happy place in their love life
um spoiler alert it's a good question
when we talk about love on this show in
particular we knew that we wanted to
look at it in all its forms so we're
looking at family love and friendship
love and romantic love there are some
incredible Canadians who are making
appearances on season two Amanda brugel
Scott Thompson what did it feel like to
have these Canadians want to take part
in a show like this it's humbling right
it's a real Testament when other actors
respond to the material for you to join
a super successful show like sort of
must be like a huge blessing who's that
oh my God is that wolf or are you wolf
Dad doesn't know the password to this
laptop it's rare to join a show or any
project that you are um actually
invested in there's also the nerves of
like joining a family and whether or not
you're gonna fit into the family they
will in with open arms and it was a
blast
[Music]